fires burned through the night in this
residential area of Cardiff
violent clashes erupted between police
and around 150 people
triggered by the deaths of two teenage
boys fifteen-year-old Harvey Evans and
16 year old Kyrie Sullivan both killed
in a crash just meters away with
significant questions over whether they
had been chased by police
in the light of day the true extent of
the damage was clear
amid the cleanup operation fires still
smoldered people's cars either smashed
or burnt out
at the scene of the crash Harvey's
godmother told Sky News the violence
broke out because of how police dealt
with the victims families
and the police just was having none of
it they wouldn't let the men the dads
come up and see their own kids laying on
the floor wouldn't even let them do
nothing it was disgusting how they
treated him yeah it was Harvey like
Harvey was a good he was amazing like a
bubbly guy
like just always always happy always on
the go
police say officers were injured during
the violence a number of arrests have
been made and police say there will be
more to be honest very scary
he didn't sleep till uh three o'clock in
the night but honestly it was terrible
I've never ever seen like that situation
in my lifetime
police say the level of violence towards
emergency services and damage to
property and vehicles was totally
unacceptable there will be questions now
to answer as to how this situation
escalated so quickly
CCTV footage appears to show two people
on a bike quickly followed by a police
van it was captured just three minutes
before the fatal crash less than half a
mile away this footage is being
recovered as part of the investigation
and will assist us in piecing together
the circumstances leading up to the
Collision
the families are being kept up to date
we can confirm that the following
investigations have been carried out so
far and when the Collision occurred
there were no police vehicles on Snowden
Road
police took no questions but the force
confirmed it has referred itself to the
police watchdog
Community leaders want calm here but
there is tension and a need for answers
as to what led to the deaths of two
young boys
damn why did Sky News in Ely Cardiff